(Applaudissements)
En 2009, j'ai acheté une maison à Detroit pour 500 dollars.
Elle n'avait pas de fenêtres, pas de plomberie, pas d'électricité
et était remplie d'ordures.
Le premier étage supportait presque 4 500 kg d'ordures,
dont la majeure partie d'une Dodge Caravan,
coupée en morceaux avec une scie à guichet.
(Rires)
J'ai vécu presque deux ans sans chauffage,
j'ai plusieurs fois été réveillé d'un sommeil profond par des coups de feu,
j'ai été attaqué par un groupe de chiens sauvages
et récupéré mes placards de cuisine d'une école abandonnée
qu'ils étaient en train de démolir.
Ça, bien sûr, c'est le Detroit dont vous entendez parler.
Ne vous méprenez pas, c'est réel.
Mais il y a aussi un autre Detroit :
un Detroit plus prometteur,
plus innovant
et qui pourrait fournir quelques réponses
aux villes qui essayent de se réinventer un peu partout.
Cependant, ces réponses ne s'inscrivent pas forcément
dans la sagesse conventionnelle d'un développement positif.
Je pense que la vraie force de Detroit se résume en deux mots :
voisinage radical.
J'étais incapable de le voir avant d'y vivre moi-même.
Il y a environ dix ans,
j'ai emménagé à Detroit, sans ami, sans travail et sans argent,
au moment où semble t-il tout le monde en partait.
Entre 2000 et 2010,
25% de la population est partie.
Cela comprenait environ la moitié des enfants en élémentaire.
Ce fut après soixante ans de déclin.
Une ville construite pour deux millions d'habitants se retrouvait
avec moins de 800 000.
Ce que l'on entend rarement, c'est que les gens ne partirent pas loin.
La population de la région métropolitaine de Detroit elle-même
est restée stable depuis les années 70.
La plupart ont quitté Detroit pour la périphérie,
alors que les 220 000 mètres carrés de la ville se détérioraient,
laissant jusqu'à plus de 60 000 mètres carrés de terres abandonnées -
environ la taille de San Francisco.
Au-delà des platitudes comme la vague « désindustrialisation » sans agent,
l'exode de Detroit peut se résumer en deux structures :
autoroutes et murs.
Les autoroutes,
associées aux énormes subventions gouvernementales
pour les périphéries au travers de prêts immobiliers et d'infrastructures,
permirent aux gens de partir comme ils le voulaient,
et avec eux la base d'imposition, le travail et les fonds pour l'éducation.
Les murs permirent que seules certaines personnes partent.
Dans nombre d'endroits,
les murs de briques et de béton séparent la ville de la périphérie,
blancs et noirs,
passant directement à travers des rues municipales
et des quartiers.
Ce sont des manifestations physiques de pratiques racistes
comme le redlining [services, prêts refusés aux gens de couleur]
clauses restrictives [refus de vente aux personnes de couleurs après accord
entre propriétaires, entreprises et municipalités]
et terreur totale.
En 1971, le Ku Klux Klan bombarda 10 bus d'école
pour éviter le transport non-discriminatoire d'étudiants.
Tout cela a fait de Detroit la métropole la plus divisée racialement
aux États-Unis.
J'ai grandi dans une ville du Michigan,
le fils d'une famille plutôt ouvrière.
Après l'université, je voulais faire quelque chose -
assez naïvement -
pour aider.
Je ne voulais pas faire partie des quelques 50% de diplômés
quittant l'État à ce moment-là,
je pensais pouvoir utiliser à la maison ma formation universitaire de luxe
pour quelque chose de positif.
J'ai lu cette grande philosophe américaine, Grace Lee Boggs,
qui vivait à Detroit,
et disait quelque chose que je ne peux oublier.
« La chose la plus radicale que j'ai fait a été de rester immobile. »
Je pensais qu'acheter une maison m'attacherait à la ville
tout en agissant comme une protestation à ces murs et autoroutes.
Subventions et prêts n'étant pas disponibles pour tous,
je décidais de procéder sans eux
et de mener mon combat personnel
contre la ville qui m'avait menacée petit avec des outils électriques.
Je trouvais finalement une maison abandonnée dans le quartier de Poletown.
C'était comme si l'apocalypse s'était abattue.
Le quartier était une prairie.
Un immense espace ouvert d'herbes hautes jusqu'à la taille
encombré de quelques structures abîmées et abandonnées
et de courageux résistants aux maisons soignées.
A 15 minutes de vélo seulement du stade de baseball du centre-ville,
le quartier était véritablement rural.
Les restes de maison ressemblaient à des cartons laissés sous la pluie ;
des monstruosités à deux étages avec de grandes coques ouvertes
et des portiques fondus.
Une des choses qui m'a le plus frappé, ce furent les rosiers,
oubliés et sauvages, accrochés aux clôtures qui s'écroulaient,
dont personne ne s'occupait plus.
C'était ma maison le jour où je la condamnais
pour la protéger des intempéries et des dégradations.
J'ai fini par l'acheter à la commune lors d'une vente aux enchères.
Je croyais le voisinage mort,
que j'étais une sorte de pionnier.
Je n'aurais pas pu plus me tromper.
Je n'étais pas un pionnier,
et commençais à comprendre combien c'était blessant.
Une des premières choses que j'appris fut d'ajouter ma voix au chœur,
non pas d'effacer ce qui se passait déjà.
(Voix cassée) Parce que le quartier n'était pas mort.
Il s’était transformé d'une façon difficile à voir
si vous n'y viviez pas.
Poletown abritait une communauté vraiment ingénieuse,
incroyablement intelligente et résiliente.
J'y ai expérimenté pour la première fois la puissance du voisinage radical.
Quand je travaillais dans ma maison avant d'y habiter,
je vivais dans une micro communauté dans Poletown,
fondée par un fermier sauvage et vertueux, qui s'appelait Paul Weertz.
Paul était professeur à l'école publique de Detroit
pour femmes enceintes et mères,
il voulait enseigner aux femmes comment éduquer leurs enfants,
en s'occupant d'abord de plantes et d'animaux.
Le taux national moyen de diplômés chez les adolescentes enceintes affiche 40%,
à l'Académie Catherine Ferguson il était souvent au dessus de 90,
grâce entre autres à l'ingéniosité de Paul.
Paul apporta cette innovation à son îlot de Poletown,
qu'il mena pendant plus de 30 ans,
achetant des maisons qui étaient abandonnées,
convaincant ses amis d'emménager et ses voisins de rester
et aidant ceux qui souhaitaient acheter la leur et la réparer.
Dans un quartier où de nombreux blocs n'ont plus qu'une ou deux maisons,
toutes les maisons de celui de Paul résistent.
C'est un témoignage du pouvoir de la communauté,
de rester à un endroit,
de prendre la responsabilité de son entourage -
de simplement le faire soi-même.
C'est le genre d'endroit où les médecins noirs vivent à côté des hipsters blancs
à côté des mères immigrées de Hongrie
ou des écrivains talentueux des jungles de Belize,
Detroit n'est pas juste blanche et noire,
et la diversité peut fleurir quand elle est encouragée.
Chaque année, les voisins se réunissent pour faire les foins,
m'enseignant combien un petit groupe peut faire beaucoup
quand ils travaillent ensemble,
et le magnétisme d'idées fantastiques et pratiques à la fois.
Le voisinage radical est présent dans chaque maison du quartier de Paul,
et plutôt que de le laisser se remplir de déchets et de désespoir
Paul et la communauté environnante en créant un jardin circulaire géant
encerclé de douzaines d'arbres fruitiers, de ruches et de parcelles de jardin
pour tous ceux qui en veulent,
m'aida à voir que nos difficultés peuvent souvent être des avantages.
Les résidents expérimentent avec l'énergie renouvelable et l’agriculture urbaine,
offrent leurs compétences et découvertes aux autres,
illustrant qu'il est inutile de supplier le gouvernement
pour avoir des solutions.
Commençons nous-mêmes.
C'est là que pendant des mois,
qu'un de mes voisins a laissé sa porte ouverte
dans une ville des plus violentes et dangereuses d'Amérique
pour que je puisse prendre ma douche avant d'aller travailler
n'en ayant pas encore une.
C'est quand il fut temps d'élever la poutre sur ma maison
qui tient la structure en l'air -
une poutre que j'avais coupée dans une usine abandonnée de la rue
quand plus aucun mur ne tenait -
une douzaine de résidents de Poletown, l'ont montée à la main.
Le voisinage radical est un zygote qui grandit dans une vision du monde
et termine dans des maisons et communautés reconstruites pour respecter l'humanité
et l'environnement.
Nous avons le pouvoir de créer le monde de nouveau ensemble
et de le faire nous-mêmes quand le gouvernement refuse.
C'est le Detroit dont vous entendez peu parler.
Le Detroit entre le délabrement pornographique d'un côté
et les cafés hipsters
et les milliardaires sauvant la ville de l'autre.
La troisième façon de reconstruire
refuse de faire les mêmes erreurs que par le passé.
En bâtissant ma maison,
j'ai trouvé quelque chose que je ne pensais pas chercher,
ce que beaucoup de « millenials » et de gens retournant à la ville recherchent.
Le voisinage radical est juste un autre mot pour communauté vraie,
celle liée par la mémoire et l'histoire,
la confiance mutuelle et la familiarité, bâtie sur des années et irremplaçable.
Comme vous avez pu l'entendre,
Detroit est en train de renaître
et se redresser des cendres du désespoir,
et les enfants et petits-enfants de ceux qui ont fui, reviennent,
ce qui est vrai.
Mais cette renaissance ne concerne qu'une partie de habitants de Detroit,
et même une petite partie d'entre eux
qui ne vivent pas au cœur de la ville.
Ce sont ceux qui vivent à Detroit depuis des générations -
ils sont majoritairement noirs.
Rien qu'en 2016,
l'année dernière,
(Voix cassée) une maison sur six à Detroit
a vu son accès à l'eau courante coupé.
Excusez-moi.
Les Nations-Unies ont parlé d'une violation des droits de l'homme.
Et depuis 2005, une maison sur trois -
réfléchissez-y, SVP -
une maison sur trois a été saisie dans la ville,
la population d'une ville comme Bufallo, dans l'État de New York.
(Reniflements)
Une maison sur trois saisie, ce n'est pas une crise de responsabilité personnelle ;
c'est systémique.
Beaucoup de gens de Detroit, dont moi,
s'inquiètent du retour de la ségrégation dans la ville même
dans le sillage de cette renaissance.
Il y a dix ans,
dans Detroit,
se retrouver dans une foule composée que de blancs était impossible.
Maintenant, c'est troublant, c'est possible.
C'est le prix que nous payons pour la résurgence économique conventionnelle.
Nous créons deux Detroit, deux classes de citoyens,
fissurant la communauté.
En contrepartie de l'argent et des aides,
de l'éclairage public,
des dollars pour les stades, des publicités trompeuses
et du buzz positif,
on coupe l'eau à des dizaines de milliers de personnes
vivant près des Grands Lacs,
la source d'eau la plus grande au monde.
Séparé a toujours signifié inégal.
C'est une faute grave pour nous tous.
Quand le développement économique expose la communauté,
il n'y a pas que ceux qui perdent leur maison
ou l'accès à l'eau qui sont touchés,
mais on casse des petits bouts de notre propre humanité aussi.
Personne ne peut être vraiment libre,
personne ne peut vraiment être confortable,
tant que nos voisins ne le sont pas.
Pour ceux qui arrivent,
cela veut dire faire attention de ne pas contribuer par mégarde
à la destruction de la communauté,
et de suivre l’exemple
de ceux qui travaillent sur ces problèmes depuis des années.
A Detroit, ça veut dire que les citoyens moyens assurent eux-mêmes
la création de points d'eau pour ceux qui en ont perdu l'accès.
Clergé et enseignants pratiquent la désobéissance civile
bloquant les camions coupant l'eau.
Ce sont des organisations qui rachètent des maisons saisies pour leurs habitants,
combattent la désinformation des ventes forcées sur les réseaux sociaux
et des hotlines tenues bénévolement.
Pour moi, c'est aider les autres à réinstaller les poutres
de leurs maisons autrefois abandonnées,
ou aider à éduquer les privilégiés,
qui s'installent dans les villes,
sur comment arriver et soutenir
plutôt que contraindre les communautés en place.
C'est participer quand un petit groupe de voisins décide
de racheter une maison saisie
et la rend à ses occupants.
Et pour vous, pour nous tous,
cela revient à trouver un rôle dans nos propres communautés.
Cela revient à vivre votre vie à l'image du monde dans lequel vous voulez vivre.
Cela revient à faire confiance à ceux qui connaissent les problèmes -
les gens qui les vivent -
avec des solutions.
Je sais qu'une troisième voie est possible parce que je l'ai vécue.
Je la vis encore maintenant
dans un quartier appelé Poletown
dans une ville des plus dénigrées au monde.
Si c'est possible à Detroit,
c'est possible peu importe où vous êtes.
Au cours des dix dernières années, en construisant ma maison,
je n'ai pas tant appris sur l’électricité, la plomberie ou la menuiserie -
bien que j'aie appris ces choses -
mais que le vrai changement, le changement réel,
commence d'abord avec la communauté,
avec un sens radical de ce que veut dire être voisin.
Cela a au moins transformé une maison abandonnée en un foyer.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)